hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Plato's Phaedo
the dialogue in the discussion between
Socrates and the two Thebans simius and
kbase there's a number of arguments that
are made concerning the immortality of
the soul either for or against and I
would like to try to treat these in
separate separate groups in part because
there's a lot of them and I think that
it would be useful to break them down
some of them are quite complex and have
a lot of different things going on a lot
of presuppositions being made so in this
video what I'm going to look at is
actually the very last set of arguments
for and against the immortality of the
soul so we need to start with with kbase
or CB so however you want to pronounce
it and one of his worries about the
immortality of the soul he's drawing an
analogy and what he says is the soul
clearly is something longer-lasting more
durable than the body and although this
is presupposing that the soul you know
has a number of successive lives and
that it leaves the body at death goes
walk into whatever world that is and
there's all sorts of stuff about that
fado and doing other videos about yeah
then it's reunited with the body Liz for
a while
separates from the body and death and
then once again goes on so the soul
clearly outlives any one single given
body over time because it enters into
contact with a lot of other bodies but
he says maybe the soul could be
something like this and he's making this
analogy
maybe the soul is like a weaver who he
has woven the number of coats and why is
he using this example well you know the
soul actually sort of weaves according
to this notion the soul sort of weaves
the body into something living it
infiltrates it and organizes that the
soul is the principle of life in in
platonic philosophy so a weaver has
woven for himself many different coats
or cloaks or pick whatever article of
clothing works for you right so the
weaver has worn many of them over time
and they wear out eventually this jacket
actually came with a the things already
on the sleeves but you know a lot of
academics end up wearing their jackets
out and they start to get kind of
threadbare so the idea is that this
Weaver has lived a long time he's
produced a lot of different garments and
he has one garment for a while then that
one breaks down and rambles then he has
another garment that he has another
garment now he dies and Sammy says
here's the argument that I'm making
about the soul let's say somebody comes
in says I don't believe that the weaver
is dead because look over there there's
his coat and we know that Coach don't
last as long as human beings so clearly
if that coat still around then he's
still around where is he
so KB's is saying maybe the soul is kind
of like that so you know you started out
with the soul and this could go through
a lot of different succession soul is on
its own then it's United with the body
and in death the body dies soul
continues eventually reunites with
another body takes that on
dies again and what happens in death is
the soul separates from the body without
the soul the body just you know break
down into its constituent parts and then
finally it's in the last conglomerate
the last integrated soul and body the
person but this time the soul has
actually worn itself out through this
successive you know interchange with
bodies the idea is that you know being
engaged with the body is actually not
something particularly good for the soul
and the soul dies and then soon
afterwards the body dies couldn't it be
like that isn't that plausible so now if
this is the case if this is something
possible then you can't say well
necessarily the soul must be immortal
and must live on after this particular
death that I'm going to experience in
this life with this body so this would
be a real challenge and Socrates
actually treats this a little bit
differently than he does simius is a
ideas about me to the souls of harmony
and all that he says we've got actually
got to bring out the big guns on this
one we have to bring out some some real
metaphysical principles the discussion
of opposites and here you actually have
to to a certain extent presuppose the
Platonic doctrine of forms so I'm going
to presume some some familiarity with
that on the part of the viewers but not
an awful lot put in a nutshell the
Platonic doctrine of the forms is saying
that for any sort of thing that we
encounter in our experience that has
certain you know qualities that we can
predicate we can say like for instance
saying that something is just or
something is beautiful there is an
absolute justice or absolute beauty or
absolute whatever it is out there and
that exists and that is unchanging
eternal that's the form or the idea and
everything over here in the world that
we experience participates in that and
is what it is because it participates in
this so if we take beauty for example
beautiful things I'll participate in the
form of beauty and the form of beauty is
what makes them in return beautiful so
it's it's prior to them they are
changing you know they're not actually
completely beautiful they're beautiful
from this perspective but not that
perspective they're beautiful at this
time but not at that time whereas this
is always beautiful it's always the same
and this is ontologically or
metaphysically prior to any individual
thing as a matter of fact in other
places he talks about these as sort of
copies so the form is what makes the
thing that kind of thing and the form
also makes that thing become what it is
so when for example something becomes
greater or larger it becomes larger by
virtue of participating more in
largeness the idea of largeness the
ideal form that's out there somewhere
when it becomes smaller there's an
opposite to largest then it becomes
smaller by virtue of smallness so this
is this is what you would call in in
certain respects or what comes to be
called a realistic understanding ideas
or realistic understanding of universals
now that's needed in order to make this
whole argument that socrates is going to
adduce work he starts out by actually
making some some comparisons so you got
three three guys they know
let me ask in Socrates and theta was a
big guy CBS is a medium-sized guy
Socrates is a little guy shortcut so
what's the relationships between them
fado
is larger or bigger than simius simius
in return is smaller and similarly
samia's is larger and Socrates lar and
Socrates is smaller than simulant of
course you know transitively Socrates
would also be smaller than fado fada
would be larger than Socrates you know
but he doesn't worry about that so
greater and smaller are relative terms
but greatness and smallness
according to Plato are not actually
relative terms their ideals or forms
that are actually out there someone
there are absolute realities and fado is
larger than simius not by being fato but
because of his size and his size is a
participation in largeness or greatness
likewise Socrates is smaller than simius
not by being Socrates the thing but by
having that quality of smallness which
participates in the form of smallest
simius actually participates in in both
he has the quality of smallness in
comparison to fado but he has the
quality of largeness and in comparison
to socrates so he's actually
participating in both and at the same
time but not in the same way you might
say well you know here this Plato is
actually violating his own his own
canons or maybe the law of the excluded
middle it's not because you know it's in
relation to something else
now what mileage is he gonna get out of
this why does Socrates bringing this up
so he says absolute greatness is never
itself both great and small it's just
great it's just a gigantic or I suppose
we have to say you know the most immense
thing in reality now the greatness that
is in other things doesn't admit of or
accept smallness its opposite its
ontological opposite what happens
instead so let's say we're looking now
at simius and he is larger than Socrates
but see me as suddenly shrinks somebody
uses a shrink ray on him Plato doesn't
have that idea but you know just go with
that the largeness that is in simius at
the approach of smallness it either is
extinguished it ceases to be and that
smallness comes in or it goes somewhere
else where it goes
Plato doesn't actually say but it goes
somewhere else the point is when
something is receiving an opposite an
opposite quality would erase a little
bit here what is happening is that in
the process of change it's losing one
quality and accepting the opposite
quality so we have a thing and it has
quality X and X and we'll call it an t
axis are opposites to each other right
so when this thing has this this quality
but this is coming in this is going to
enter into that thing this is the sort
of metaphorical way of saying it is
going to make that thing have this
quality instead of that quality what
happens is before that happens this has
to either go away or it has to go
somewhere else
and it's no longer there in this thing
which means now that this changes to an
TX so you know small things become large
large things become small beautiful
things become ugly ugly things become
beautiful we can go on and on and on
with this there are some things though
this is why Socrates brings up the
examples that he does there's some
things where this can't work out quite
the same way and he uses two main
examples for this one is numerical in
terms of even and odd and actually I
don't want to go into that one I much
rather prefer the physical that natural
philosophy one that he's going to
explore but she has to do with fire and
with snow so granted you know in our
frame of reference as far as Natural
Sciences go these are really not that
parallel snow is a form that water takes
on the underlying substance is really
water fire is really you know several
different things taking place you know
from a natural science perspective it's
combustion it's the radiating radiation
heat it's also the processes by which
things are decomposing and okay granted
Plato didn't have an access to that
Natural Science let's let's see where
he's going with this before we start
worrying about that so what is fire fire
has hotness right so fired has heat snow
and it's turn has cold and the question
is what happens then when it's opposite
approaches the opposite the heat is cold
right the opposite to cold is heat so
far so good
now given the logic given what we've
worked out so far what would actually
take place
so let's take fire first cold is
approaching imagine that that it's like
you know a very cold wind or something
like that you know certain fires can
actually be put out by lowering the
temperature so there is some some
natural science that's right as the cold
approaches the cold and the heat can not
be in the same thing at the same time it
can either be cold or it can be hot
forgetting you know about middle ranges
because he doesn't talk about that here
so if the cold is going to make its way
in one thing has to happen either the
heat has to just be wiped out or the
heat has to go away somewhere else and
then the cold enters in but what is fire
if it doesn't have heat heat is
something that is essential to fire so
what is it what happens that when the
cold enters in it doesn't just kick the
heat out it actually destroys the fire
the fire is no longer in existence it's
no longer what it was by an opposite
coming yet similarly heat what does heat
due to snow yeah we know it melts it
turns it into water but well you know
look let's go with this see what Plato
is trying to say as the heat comes in
the cold is destroyed or it goes
somewhere else what has to happen then
heat is within the snow and the snow is
and snow destroyed this is the way
opposites work and you notice Plato is
is using these sort of metaphysical
opposites in terms of you know ideal
forms but also in terms of qualities
that that things have somebody like
Aristotle will consider this later on
and you know treat this in somewhat
different ways so so far so good
now let's think about instead of a
considering other examples let's think
about the soul
what is the soul what qualities does it
have well among the quality is that the
soul has all right life
as a matter of fact in a certain way the
soul doesn't just have life or
participate in life in a certain way the
soul is actually the principle of life
the bearer of life that gives life to
the body the body is not alive unless
it's conjoined with the soul what
happens then when death approaches well
remember what are our two alternatives
either the life must be extinguished in
the soul or the life must go somewhere
else right well here's where it gets
really interesting here's where you
might not actually accept the argument
this is really the critical point if
you've accepted everything else up to
this point what is death Plato has
already dealt with this as being when
the soul and the body are separated out
from each other right so the body no
longer has life as a matter of fact the
body can accept death within it so we
know that death is going there right
what about here
can't go there can life leave the soul
so that death can enter in well death is
the separation of the soul and the body
so yeah in a certain sense things that
we have the soul can separate from the
body but death in the sense of
dissolution in the sense of break down
you know complete cessation ceasing to
be no because the soul is the principle
so what can it do the soul please it
goes somewhere else at the approach of
death death never touches the soul think
of it sort of like magnets you know as
one magnet gets closer repulses the
other one because they're their
opposites to each other well actually
they're not opposites of the same one
same polarity but you get the idea right
this is a pretty ingenious way of
explaining what's going on death never
actually does end up arriving at the
soul it just sort of grabs onto the body
instead kills that separates it off from
the soul soul goes off as soul of the
dead dead person and goes off to some
other future life where it continues its
existence as a matter of fact if you've
actually done things right as a
philosopher you might not get reborn at
all but it continues an existence
according to Plato death in the sense of
dissolution complete breakdown ceasing
to be cannot touch it now the question
that you have to ask yourself at this
point is is this a good argument or are
there any flaws in the argument and I
think there's two things that the two
ways you want to look at this one is are
you willing to accept the metaphysical
premises from which Plato is starting so
if you don't accept those then you're
not gonna accept the argument right or
you're gonna say well it doesn't have to
be like this there's no necessity to the
argument so if you don't accept those
premises right off the bat you know like
say the doctrine of forms or Plato's
understanding of opposition the game's
over
maybe it's not so interesting if that's
the case even if that is the case you
can go on and ask a further set of
questions granted that these premises
are true would the conclusion
necessarily follow or has there been
anything hinky and he sort of sleight of
hand going on here that Plato himself
either didn't realize or put out there
is a bad argument for us to try to
figure out you know
maybe there's there's you know a better
argument or maybe this could be shored
up well the real problem with this aside
from some of the you know natural
science assumptions and all I wish we
know don't work which is not very
interesting really what you know this is
an interesting thing because of the way
in which they are going to set up
there's kind of an equivocation isn't
there a meaning the word is used in
several different ways for both death
and life there's an equation of the soul
with life that's a little bit different
than the equation of snow with cold or
fire with heat if the soul really is
life itself and cannot accept death does
that mean that my soul is in your soul
or there's some sort of soul out there
form of the soul that's in every soul if
it gets very very confusing at this
point if we follow this out that's what
I'm gonna leave this off I'm not going
to try to you know resolve this I'm just
gonna say maybe there's something
questionable here you know there's the
metaphysical postulates or premises and
then there's the way in which the
argument itself is conducted if you
actually accept these this is not a bad
response maybe this this could in fact
be a depiction of the way things work
for some other reason but that's where
I'm going to leave off with with this
argument